ja es hat gerade wieder sirenen alarm
gegeben hier in kiew dreimal ist die
sirene angegangen wir gehen davon aus
dass es hier um die kämpfe in den
vororten geht insbesondere nimmt ihnen
und butscher und von dort hören wir das
ist schwere heftige kämpfe gibt um diese
vororte von care von das ist da momentan
für die russische armee darum geht mehr
voran zu kommen näher heranzukommen die
an kiew auch an das zentrum und das beim
versuch aus einem dieser vororte zu
flüchten drei zivilisten ums leben
gekommen sind das sind medienberichte
aus der ukraine die wir noch nicht
bestätigt haben aber laut ukrainischen
medienberichten drei tote zivilisten
beim versuch aus alpin hier nach kiew zu
kommen pauli open air ist ein vorort von
kiew nicht weit weg wie sehr spürt man
tatsächlich diesen vormarsch diese
einschläge noch in der hauptstadt bei
dir
ja heute morgen zwischen 9 und 9.30
haben wir das auch hier sehr klar
gespürt und immer wieder gehört die
einschläge auch die artillerie und die
gefechte die es dort gibt
unser übersetzer steht in kontakt auch
mit menschen in diesen vororten
teilweise ist es sehr schwierig dort
kontakt zu halten weil der strom
komplett ausgefallen ist bereits und wo
es auch probleme nicht nur mit der
elektrizität auch mit dem wasser gibt
zum beispiel noch viel schlimmer ist die
situation in mariupol der stadt im osten
des landes dort sieht man teile der
stadt bereits völlig in schutt und asche
gebombt wir sehen was putins raketen was
putins bomben anrichten und das was dort
passiert da geht man davon aus dass
genau das das vorbild ist was putin auch
hier mit der hauptstadt vor hat was wird
jetzt in den nächsten stunden für kiew
erwartet oder ist die situation so
unklar dass man überhaupt nichts
prognostizieren kann
es kann jederzeit jede minute jede
stunde alles passieren in der ukraine in
kiew an jedem ort dafür ist genügend
russisches militär vor ort alle die das
analysieren was die russische armee
macht sagen allerdings dass es noch
etwas zeit brauchen wird für den sturm
auf die hauptstadt auf die innenstadt
das dazu neues militärgerät neue
soldaten weitere soldaten hier in diese
richtung kommen müssten und die frage
ist dann auch was genau hat putin am
ende vor villa wirklich die hauptstadt
in schutt und asche legen wie groß die
1999 wie aleppo 2016/17 die villa hier
vorgehen und was will er damit dem land
machen das ist auch die debatte gerade
wo die menschen sagen er wenn er das
land in schutt und asche gebombt wie
will er sozusagen hier mit den menschen
weiter umgehen will er das ja sozusagen
das chaos immer weitergeht und die
hoffnung ist da weiterhin natürlich dass
es irgendeinen anderen weg gibt wir
haben gehört dass der israelische
premierminister gestern bei wladimir
putin war und danach nach deutschland
weitergeflogen ist zu olaf scholz dass
wir natürlich hier genau registriert
auch in der ukraine
ich stand in kontakt auch mit beratern
des ukrainischen präsidenten die ja
natürlich die hoffnung haben und die
unbedingt wollen an einem tisch zu
sitzen sie längst wunsch ist dass das in
israel stattfinden könnte wollen wir
hoffen dass die diplomatischen
bemühungen irgendwann auch früchte
tragen paul dankeschön für den moment
nach kiew